twenty years ago it was a novelty a new
currency across much of europe as one
central bank took on responsibility for
the monetary policy of hundreds of
millions of people for much of its first
decade the eurozone seemed to prosper
but then came the global financial
crisis with the greeks needing a
succession of eu states unable to pay
their national debts and close to
defaulting on them and therefore
dropping out of the euro club
brussels became the place for seemingly
endless meetings about bailout packages
with growing tensions between richer
northern and poorest southern european
member states
between 2010 and 2012 there were endless
predictions that the euro was going to
fall apart or at least that it would
lose some of its weakest members like
like greece in the end none of those
forecasts came true when the covid
pandemic seemed to shake the integrity
of the eurozone angela merkel and
emmanuel macron solved the crisis with
the so-called corona bonds effectively
using the assets of the rich member
states to guarantee the debts of the
worst-hit nations
now the ecb's main foe is inflation
driven by fast increasing energy prices
and supply shortages when the euro was
being dreamt up some wondered if the
plan was a currency to challenge the
dollars supremacy
today euro has managed to establish
itself as the second
global most important currency
concerning for example the
forex market or a debt market
and in the international payments for
example its role is almost equal to the
dollar
the driving force behind the single
currency comes from paris and berlin the
new german government will
continue to
closely cooperate with the french
government
and i assure you that the franco-german
tandem
will stay
essential for the further development of
the european union and the european
monetary union opinion polls both across
the eurozone and the wider eu suggest
broad popular support for the single
currency a trend that has been stable
throughout its existence
twenty years ago hundreds of millions of
europeans had to adapt to the new notes
and coins in their pockets
and soon they may have to again because
the ecb has announced an overhaul of the
look and feel of its cash
dominick kane al jazeera berlin